[Music]
what's up guys
i know my voice sounds weird my
allergies are kicking
like bruce lee um but we're here at the
new studio
it's all coming together we're gonna
have the table in today
the artists getting to work and she has
a deadline that she has to do
so everybody's under pressure right now
so let's see
the progress you'll see it's getting
there it's getting
[Music]
that's my
[Music]
i think we got stevie in and then we got
nick at the controls we got chin he's
gonna jam out some music he came in with
literally a one-man band like he's from
venice beach
huh what you gonna play some metallica
do you think karaoke we got some
metallica we got some tracy chapman
you got some air clapped there yeah
that's my jam
drop so fast with a million miles i
forget the name uh
we'll see if i can sing with my aloe g's
not allergic to this pup though i'm
thinking about stealing from nick
i need a dog my kids want a dog
that's my [ __ ]
[Music]
you thought i was doing all this
you know i am dude i've changed you have
changed man went to nashville
where's stephen when i met you you're
making two grand a weekend dog with you
now
no yeah i was always making more than
you a weekend never
oh dude when you were fighting you were
making 700 reasons i was making three
cents to get punched in the face
so then i was making more what's up
what's up player yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she took off all the
[Music]
no biggie just everything we've been
working for
first fight companion cowbest fight
companion
all set up it's a live team it's always
tricky live
live is tricky kids now i'm excited
nervous anxiety that everything worked
out but yeah
and we don't i think everyone here is
pretty much pretty pro i think
my i think ronnie's about to have that
400 yeah so he's got wonderboy by by ko
um anything else happens i win thousand
[Music]
dollars
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh
let's take him down dude
connor four grand i can't
go let's go let's go
let's go let's
that's why i love it it's not my money
oh this is good
[ __ ] yep yes this is nice
yeah trying to finish them here oh yeah
oh i love it
out bradley's bed blowing up that you
won money
let's go dude 4k
double or not take [ __ ] connor
and you still want to be ringside no i'm
glad i'm here
i'm glad i could be here to take
brendan's money
and you so you want to pay me more money
yeah but you got to you have to i don't
i just don't want to [ __ ] take conor
mcgregor let me hold on hold on
dude conor mcgregor yeah i know
the notorious yeah
back against the wall dublin's finals i
was with you i was with you
we were taking dustin though dude i
thought we were taking that look at
proper 12.
i haven't got proper 12 here it's a sign
it's not a sign you just have whiskeys
here
that's really not a sign you just have
[ __ ] four whiskeys that's wonderful
yeah right
i i just oh listen
i feel i kind of feel bad thank you so
much
either way it didn't matter still but
yeah um i feel kind of bad for taking
your money
on your show yeah wow just
listen i i'll
[ __ ] it double or nothing [ __ ] it
let's [ __ ] go let's go i'm kind of
doing it oh my god
i'm in the hole right now dude if you
i'm in
[Music]
i don't need the money i'm giving you
500. yeah already yeah okay
it's all good i'm sweating two 4k hey
all right so wait wait wait so my 500 is
going into this i guess right oh yeah
yeah okay okay so there you go okay so
am i doubling up then
i get a thousand then if we win four
yeah
so we're taking we're taking connor
we're taking connor we're taking all
right we're connor
let's go buddy let's go i got the
[ __ ]
no he was he was the guy was supposed to
win but not by knockout yeah
that was a plus but he didn't win
anyways he wouldn't fight him he didn't
know he was the fight either so you were
lost either way
you think that guy lost that fight no
yeah yeah yeah he probably yeah you
can't share with god
at least two to one if not some people
had three nothing but i had a two to one
for gilbert yeah yeah two to one
yeah yeah what do you say i don't know
my buddy just text me is it sugar versus
no love
with the i am like i didn't okay okay
that's why we need subtitles man listen
i don't
know i'm calling it well this is this is
better go let's go no love
come get some [ __ ] so what are we
talking
about 125 son do this meet at 130 man
says
i want cody next no one else you wanted
to
oh my god how do you feel about that
yeah talk to us
man i like uh i like easy money
i
here's the thing cody when i look at
that fight
that i'm not and i'm not hitting like
kill that kid put on a fantastic
performance
but i look at that fight and i'm like
that might be a tougher fight for sugar
shawn good i don't
want to give it to him that's what he
wants to do you're talking slow
that's the other main event that's
either main event of fight night
sorry dude he's [ __ ] you that's how bad
it is
he does something where he steps back
look it broke it just broke when he
stepped
[ __ ] oh i hate watching [ __ ] like that
man
yeah that was a [ __ ] angle too you
saw it from like look it just
stepped on it he just stepped on it
[Music]
first one b what do you think i went
pretty well
almost lost 4k my boy bradley
i didn't even want that bad damn it [ __ ]
you can we
[Laughter]
what's up guys good news the squad pick
the lucky winner because we reached over
25 000 subscribers i think we're on our
way to 40
already so they're a little late on the
jump picking 25 but we picked it
uh i have nothing to do with this it's
random so
don't be upset but you can still have a
chance to win because we're gonna pick
another winner at 50
75 100 125 150 175 200
all the way up to who god knows what but
for the first 25k subscriber winner
it is our boy sheldon white so sheldon
white you won
let us know where you're coming in from
we'll cover everything flight
hotel wherever it is you're coming here
we'll figure out the date and time
whatever works for your schedule but get
your mind right dude because you're
lifting with me
my boy mark harley chappelle backflip
lacy at zoo culture
you can sit on on firing the kid king
the sting below the belt
fight campaign whatever you want to do
with sheldon white you're up my man get
your mind right
get that pre-workout going try not to
[ __ ] your pants but you're up buddy